this is casa su high-speed digicam the
FC 100 which shoots up to 1,000 frames a
second as you can see the geyser cassia
don't trust us at anything they put it
on a pistol grip lollipop stick with a
court so we can't steal it we like this
camera because there's a lot of things
never seen in a compact digital camera
before first he shoots a burst mode
which means you'll never miss a shot you
press the button and hold it down the
camera runs very quaint a second then
afterwards you go through back through
those pictures and you pick the one you
want so you never catch the person with
their eyes closed then you can tune it
up at 1,000 frames a second this drops
the resolution down to a tiny box but
then you get high speed photography that
you're never going to get anywhere else
third is at mode which kind of goes back
in time you put into this mode the
camera record to constantly then when
you press the button it grabs a second
before and a second after if you miss
the shot press the button and you
actually capture you can also see on the
back of the camera lots and lots of
buttons every one of the modes as its
own dedicated button to access it so you
don't have to go digging through menus
to find everything which makes it a lot
lot quicker to use some of the things
you'll recognize right here you have
your standard playback and record by
this but this camera doesn't have
separate modes for stills and video here
you press to take videos here you press
to take a regular picture up here you
press this button to go to the 30 frames
burst mode here you enter slow motion
which is what we were doing earlier with
the cheerleaders so when can you get
your hands on this thing the absolutely
one hundred will be available in March
and it will cost you three hundred
ninety nine dollars